the green color of leaves is due to this
pigment called chlorophyll right which
absorbs sunlight and converts it into
energy through the process called
photosynthesis I'm sure you all must be
aware of it but despite that not all
leaves are actually great in color this
is because of the presence of different
kinds of pigments in the plant leaf
cells for instance they can be purple in
color or blue or red in color even
yellowing color did you know that so
high concentration of chlorophyllana
leaf will give it its green color now
there's a pigment called carotenot and a
high concentration of that will impart a
yellow or yellowish orange color to the
leaf similarly anthocyanin pigment will
impart a purple color to the leaf
amazing isn't it now tell me in the
comments section below what are some
plants which not only have green leaves
but also these column leaves right and
for more such videos subscribe to don't
know guys and hit the Bell icon so that
you don't miss out on any future
approach